we're on problem 115 Mary's income is
60% more than Tim's income so Mary its
income 60% more than Tim's
so that's one point six times Tim's
income I mean you could write it as
Tim's income plus 60 percent of Tim's
income but hopefully it's second nature
that this is just one point six times
Tim's income so as Mary's income is
equal to one point six times Tim's
income and Tim's income is forty percent
less than Juan's income so Tim's income
is if it's forty percent less than
Juan's income that means that it's 60%
of Juan's income right you could view
that is Juan's income minus 40 percent
of Juan's income that's point six times
Juan's income
what percentage of Juan's income is
Mary's income so let's just do a little
substitution substitute this 2t over
here so you get Mary is equal to 1.6
times 0.6 times 1 and then what's 6
times
let's see what's 6 times 16 60 plus 36
so Mary income let me make sure I get
that 16 times 6 yes 60 plus 36 96 and we
have one two numbers behind the decimal
point to the right of the decimal so
it's 0.9 six times Juan's income so what
are they're asking what percentage of
Juan's income is Mary's income well
Mary's income is 96% of Juan's income
and that's choice C this is point nine
six is 96 percent of problem 115 no 116
it looks like something I have to draw
each dot in the mileage table above
representatives and entry indicating the
distance between a pair of five cities
let me try to draw this out quickly so
we have five cities let me see
it's one two three four and five and
then have to do it the other way it's
one two three and four and then let's
see they have the same cities on both
axes city a B C D and E C D a B C D and
E and they have some dots there it's a
dot a dot dot dot dot and dots down that
way a fair enough
each dot and the mileage table above
represents an entry indicating the
distance between a pair of the five
cities if the table were extended to
represent the distances between all
pairs of 30 cities and each distance
were to be represented by only one entry
how many entries would the table then
have with the table then half okay so
this they're saying okay when with this
this is essentially the case with five
cities right you don't want to care
about the distance between a and a they
want the distance between all pairs of
30 cities okay so this is so this is the
case when you have n is equal to five
and the reason why you could say okay
the district a and B is this dot you
could have also said oh the difference
between a B and a is this dot right down
here but they didn't draw a dot there
because they said and each distance were
to be represented by only one entry so
they don't want to double they don't
want to double you know if this was five
this would also be five they only want
to write it there once so relative to
five how would we figure this out so if
you think about it what you're going to
have is what you're going to have is you
no matter how big this table is the
diagonal is going to be empty because
you don't want to figure out you don't
want it you don't have to fill out the
distance between a city in itself right
and then if you just continue the trend
that dated you're just going to fill up
out of what's left over you're just
going to fill out half of them because
the other half is just redundant
information
so for example if you have twenty five
if you have five if you have five cities
you're going to have five times five is
equal to twenty five squares how many
squares are gonna be in the diagonal
we're gonna have exactly five squares
the diagonal right one two three four
five so you're gonna subtract five so
you're gonna have 20 20 boxes left that
aren't in the diagonal and then you're
gonna have to fill out half of those
right so you're going to fill out
exactly ten boxes so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 so let's do the same exercise with 30
if you have 30 cities you're gonna have
30 times 30 boxes which is equal to 900
you're going to take out the 30 boxes
that are in the diagonal so minus 30 so
that's equal to 870 and then you're only
going to have to fill out half of those
because you don't want redundant
information so you're on your file let's
say the top half the way they did it in
this diagram so if you divide this by 2
divided by 2 2 you're gonna get to what
870 divided by 2 is 435 and that's
choice B next question 117 117 which of
the following has a value less than 1 so
choice a is 2 times 7 over 13 2 times 7
over 13 well 2 times 7 is 14 so that's
greater than 13 so it's not a B o4 d
there but I think that's supposed to be
B square root of 10 over 2 well square
root of 10 that's gonna be 3 point
something right which is greater than 2
so that's not right choice C well they
have it all piped up choice C is 2 over
the square root of 2 well the square
root of 2 is less than 2 it's one point
something so this is going to also have
a value greater than one so it can't be
this we're looking for less than one
choice D says 1 divided by 1/2 well
that's equal to 1 times 2 which is equal
to 2 so I can already tell you the
choice is going to be e
well let's look at it
so they have 9 over 10 squared well
that's 81 over 100 but sure enough is
definitely less than 1 so the choice is
e problem 118 that's too dark 118 the
ratio of the length to the width of a
rectangular advertising display is
approximately 3.3 to 2 so the length is
3.3 and the width is 2 at least that's
the ratios if the width of this of the
display is 8 meters
okay the ratio of the length to the
width so the width is 8 meters is 8
meters what is the approximate length of
the display in meters okay so they tell
us the length to the width is
approximately 3.3 to 2 which is
approximately equal to the length to 8
meters right they say the width of this
play is 8 meters so we just have to
solve this as best as we can before L
right so we could say - well the easiest
way to think about it is to go from 2 to
8 you multiply by 4 so to go from 3.3 to
L we have to multiply by 4 so L is equal
to 3 point 3 times 4 what's that 33
times 4 or 3.3 times 4 4 times 3 is 12 4
times 3 is 12 plus 1 is 13 one number
behind the decimal point thirteen point
two so they say approximate and the
closest one is choice C 13 problem 119
119 the average salary of 15 people in
the shipping department of a certain
firm is 50 is 20,000 people so the
average of 15 people is equal to 20,000
the salary of five of the employees is
25,000 each so we can even say the
average of those five is gonna be 25,000
because all of them make 25,000 and the
salary of the four of the employees is
16,000 each out of four of the employees
is 16,000 each that's a salary but we
can you know
if your average 16 for people making
16,000 the average going to be 16,000
what is the average salary of the
remaining employees so what's the let's
think about this so let's try to find
the average of all of the employees so
if we find the average of all 15
employees we're going to sum up all of
their salaries divided by 15 and we know
that that is going to be equal to 20,000
right that's going to be equal to 20,000
now we have these five guys making
25,000 so the sum of their salaries is
going to be 5 times 25,000 and then you
have these 4 people making 16,000 so
it's plus 4 times 16 I'm just trying to
solve up everyone salaries up here in
the numerator and I'm going to divide by
15 and then I'm going to have what the
average of the remaining people how many
people are remaining let's see I've
already done nine people so there are 6
people remaining right because there's
total of 15 people so the average of the
six remaining people times 6 right
whatever they whatever their average is
times 6 that will give you the sum of
their of their salaries and now we just
solve for the average of those six let's
see what we can do so 5 times 25 that's
125 plus 4 times 16 is 64 plus let's say
6 times
let's call it a just 6 a is equal to 20
times 15 so what's 20 times 15 20 times
10 is 220 times 5 is 100 so it's equal
to 300 let's see so we get I just want
to make sure I'm doing the math right
there's always the hardest part so 125
plus 64 is 189 plus 6ei is equal to 300
subtract 189 from both sides you get 6a
is equal to 300 minus 189 that's 1 119
is that no no 111 yeah
111 right 89 you add 11 to it you get to
200 and then you have to add another 100
to get to 300
111 300 - 189 and then how many times
does 6 go into 111 divide both sides by
6 6 goes into 111 1 times 6 goes into 51
6 goes into 51 8 times 8 times 48 and
then 3:30 eighteen point five times
eighteen point five thousand dollars is
the average of their salary and luckily
enough that's one of the choices best
choice be 18500 we did everything in
thousand so we've got eighteen point
five that's eighteen thousand five
hundred dollars
see you in the next video